so be proud I would go for this
clean theory
and therefore clean up on the beach
[Music]
I could have surfaced on the street
on the edge of the Bastille trash things 50ccb
you can imagine
[Music]
is like that of the half of the parties still
works on the construction  in painting
[Music]
so you train and the czech one could
that the lack of a place for him in this
theory that the population do a workout
the gym to pay to pay is the
money to be originals turn off santa
maria
our pm the population is very important
[Music]
[Applause] it
's pay nothing to train fantato feel
nature of soil there's a beach outdoors it
had to be better
mine is only one is to try to do gym
11 cosan thing more but dread even for
us
champions
[Applause]
[Music]
when  there was a party keep protecting
we have to train after a
swim in the sea
and it's complete
[Music]